[Musique]
qui est de vous madame dupont vous
parlez les 21 millions 400 mille madame
dupont qui je suis une bonne française
moyenne madame dupont se marie en
moyenne à 24 ans elle à environ 15% de
chances de divorcer au bout de trois ans
et l'ins 30% de chances d'être trompée
au bout de cinq ans
76% de madame dupont à porto tollé le
petit déjeuner de leur mari sauf pendant
les trois premiers mois de leur mariage
ou 45% de messieurs dupont remplissent
cet office
35% bros soigneusement les vêtements de
leurs maris ses 40% les brosses à fond
dans les moindres recoins peut-être mais
madame dupont consacrent au moins 65 eur
par mois au nettoyage de son appartement
mais dépasse 25 heures par an à vernir
ses ongles et 26 heures pour les faire
sécher oui mais ce temps est pris sur
les 360 euros annuels qu'elle perd
attendre les 70% de monsieur dupont qui
après les huit premiers mois leur
mariage ne rentre pas directement leur
travail des statistiques des marchands
de tissus il ressort qu'il est
nécessaire de dépasser 12 kg de tissus
pour un achat de 125 grammes
au fond voyez vous madame dupont et 100%
conservatrice elle scrute les choses
avec attention l os et des sites quais
la toute dernière extrémité pour les
solutions radicales
22% de mesdames dupont consomme 30
paquet de biscottes par mois pour garder
la ligne avec une petite fiche est de
woerth ne méritent bien car c'est pas la
gourmandise que 30 % d'entre elles
peuvent arracher leur mari à la lecture
de leur journal
30% de mesdames des ponts d'or met en
chemise de nuit c'est des sens et c'est
ce que nous préférons
50% des revenus c'est économique et 20%
en pyjama dont elle n'utilise d'ailleurs
que la veste et fantaisiste nos
statistiques très étudiée établissent
qu'en général six soirs sur sept
monsieur dupont laisse à sa femme le
loisir de rêver de rêver à la voiture de
ses rêves qui lui permettra de gagner un
temps précieux pour tous qu'elle n'a pas
pu faire dans sa journée et le
s'endormir heureuse comme les 21
millions 400 mille autres mesdames
dupont heureuse malgré tout de vivre en
france avec 21 millions de monsieur
dupont
[Musique]